マンケートジュニアで 私の興奮したので、ヤマハ
は日本語の絆をうまく研究しましたほとんどの
話はそこにあるはずがありませんあなたは会うでしょう
私はコメンテーターのチェックステッカーとして私たちをカットしまし
た これを見た
ということは、10年前に書いたヒーローと呼ばれる作品を今から読まなければならないということです。
2010年1月28日それはとても悲しいことです。
昨日午後6時40分に亡くなった友人のロジャースワン
ロジャーがこのウェブサイトの私のゲストライターの一人だったことを知らない
人のために、私の古い
ウェブサイトで彼は東京の棚と呼ばれるコラムを書き、
そこで彼は日本の小説を
レビューし
ました。 海外の東京で、最近
彼はジェットプログラムに取り組んだ彼の経験の同様のブログを振って購入し
ました
ロジャーは私と同じように多くの方法で人生を送りまし
たが、それをしましたが
、アネラが
今日彼の周りのすべての人を包み込んだ具体的な暖かさでそれをしました 私が
知っていたロジャースワンと
彼が私の人生に与えた影響について書きます
2008年9月13日にロジャースワンに会いました
2008年彼はシンケル大崎市役所に向かう途中のバスで私の隣に座っていました
こんにちは
私は言った シアトル
から来ました。ミシガンから来ました。
シリアル作りで有名な町から来
ました。日が経つにつれ、ロジャーとの最初の出会い
でした。ロジャーが隣に住んでいることを知りました。
私にとっては、私と
同じように小さなドアマンマシンの川崎ロジャーです。私
はアルコールを飲んだり薬を飲んだりしたことがありませんでした。
これは寮では珍しいことでした。
そのため、2人はすぐにクリック
して、学年の前に定期的に話し始めました。
ある日、
ロジャーの声が窓から浮かんでいるのを聞いて興味をそそられたのを覚えて
います。バルコニーをのぞいて、
ロジャーが大人気で頻繁に取り上げられるyoutubeシリーズの最初のエピソードを撮影しているのを発見しました。
このビデオ
ここにある小さな映画みんなええ
みんなみんな
東京白鳥の最初の記事へようこそ私は
知らない人のための白鳥ですそしてここに私
は川崎神奈川にいます。
横浜ですが、とにかく
素敵な場所がたくさん
あり、とても素敵な場所
です。寮もとても嬉しいです。とても
素晴らしいので、ここの人たちは
本当にみんなです。 いいですね。
今年
は東京タワーのそばにある慶應義塾大学の留学生
です。参加できてとても嬉しいです。そこに
行くことができてとても
嬉しかったです。素晴らしい機会でした。
家に帰るすべての人と、日本の
クールなショットを見たいと思っているWeb上の人のために、いくつかのビデオを作成します。
これは、
私がみんなの弟に会っ
たロジャースワンです。
エルトン・ジョンが
ヴィンテージのビンテージセガ
ドリームキャストゲームを収集しているのを聞いているか
、疑わしい見知らぬ人の目の前でカメラに直接話しかけて
いましたが、ロジャースの行動にはほとんど
常に緊張感がありました
が、彼は情熱を隠そうとしませんでしたこれは私が会ったロジャーです
しかし
、
2007年から2008年のプルームのいずれかが居住者であるか、
秋の四半期の1koレベル1の日本の
コースが彼を証明できるため、昨日亡くなったロジャースワンではありません。
慶應義塾大学の日本語クラスにも参加して
いただけでなく
、1日5
時間、週5日、5か月間、隣同士に座っ
ていました。勉強を真剣に受け止め、
15分から20分前までいつも教室にいました。
クラスが始まる前のクラスですが、ドアを開けるたびに
、
ロジャーは静かに
彼を一人で買うか、カメラと会話することを勉強していました。
皆さん、
今日は東京白鳥の別のエピソードの時間です。
慶應義塾大学の土曜日の朝、
これは
私が見ることができるクラスの1つであり
、土曜日の朝のクラスで知っていることは私にはかなり異質ですが、
実際には
かなり早く慣れ
ます。 土曜日の9時頃から12時15分くらいまでの授業
は
日曜日が休みなので
、今日は
慶應義塾大学八神キャンパスでお祭りがあります。  atは
実際に
はこのキャンパスがどこにあるかよりもずっと私の寮に近いですこれは
約1時間離れたキャンパスの会合ですので私は
あなたがクラスに着くための1時間の旅を知っていることを知っている必要があります
先生に呼ばれたロジャーは
、最初のビデオを作ったときと同じように答え
、クラスの残りの人たち
がすべての質問の終わりに微笑んでいたので、
これは私が会ったロジャースワンでしたが、そうではあり
ませんでした。 昨日亡くなったロジャースワン
お風呂の家に一緒に行きたいねえ男ロジャーに聞いてみた
アンドリュー
確かにジェニーはおそらくこれが
最初の月の終わりまでに誰もが彼を知っていた理由です
あなたはロジャーに会ったことがあります彼はそのよう
な静かな男ですええ彼は完全に冷静
です
寮は愛想が良かったのかもしれませんが、
彼
は定期的に彼の人生を記録し、
それを世界に見せていたので、彼と話をしなくても誰もがその男についてすべてを知っ
てい
たビデオでした。 本当に大きな
ことなので、
窮屈なプルームから出てエレベーターに出くわし
たときは、いつも何か話したいことがあり
、隠すことは何もありませんでした。
寮のみんながロジャースのビデオを見て
、彼の真剣な情熱を祝い始めました。
なぜ私たちはあなたが私を祭りに迎えたのか
、そして私はタコのボールを食べるのが待ちきれません。
円とこれで私の一日はとても
灰色になり、ロジャー
は寮の他のメンバーから招待状を受け取り始め
、彼の快適ゾーンから赤ちゃんの一歩を踏み出しました
ねえルーク調子はどう
ですかケビン私はちょうど戻ってきましたf
ロジャーと一緒に浴場からロジャーと一緒に待つ
私は
彼が撮影しなかった私の耳をほとんど信じられませんでした彼は
それについて完全にクール
でした
ロジャースの部屋に彼はドアを開けて、
その週の少し後に行われる予定だった彼の誕生日パーティーに私を招待しましたが
、ロジャー
は東京白鳥の新しい顔でみんなが冗談を言った親しみやすさの愚か者に自分自身を飲み込んだので、別の変化がありました
そして、新しい顔は
後で大丈夫です
[音楽]
ロジャーはすぐにプルームの住人とより深く関わり
、渋谷で飲み物を飲みに
出かけたり、古い私から古い私への日帰り旅行をしたり
、ポケモンをしたりします
この頃、ロジャー
にガールフレンドと
、東京に住む若い女性と恋に落ちたときにクリスマスに贈りたいものについて話し始め、
彼女に
クリスマスに特別な何かを贈りたいと決心しました。
ガールフレンドがいなかったロジャーは、相談する
人の可能性が最も高いわけではありませんでし
たが、ロジャーの中で
最もロマンチックなアドバイスを持っていることが、当時のガールフレンドのために書い
た非常に短い本を改訂して編集するのに役立ちまし
た。 ほぼ一列の
紙と1年分のインクだったに違いない
これは私が
決して忘れないもので
あり、ロジャー・スワンがページ
をめくったときに彼が泡立つのを見ていた私のお気に入りの思い出は
、それを与えるよりもほとんど良かったです 私の
当時のガールフレンド自身に、
彼は最後の仕上げに関して彼が私に与えた追加のアイデアを持っていましたが、それは私が
自分では考えられなかったものでしたが
、私の
当時のガールフレンドを涙にさせた
磨きのポイントは私が知っていたが知らなかったロジャースワンです
昨日亡くなったロジャースワンは、
ロジャーが特別なもののために引っ張ったオーバーザトップのロマンティックスを聞き過ぎて聞いて自分自身を愛しているので、ロジャーは与えるべきたくさんの愛のアドバイスを持っていたこと
がわかりました
青い私のお尻の誰かが
おそらく初めて私が言っ
たのはとてもかわいいですロジャープレイボーイ
彼が自分のためにゲームするニックネームは
他の人を笑顔にすること以外に何も愛しておら
ず、それを実現するために何でも喜んでしました
そして彼はすべてをしました
そして それは私たち全員を笑顔にしました
[音楽]
この直後、ロジャー
は日本に戻ったときに彼の家族や友人を訪ねるためにアメリカに戻って短い旅行をしまし
た、そして私たちは長いキャッチアップセッションをしました ケビン彼
は私
があなたがかなりフィットネスに夢中になっていることを知っている私が知っている多くの異なる方法で自分自身を改善しよ
うと決心したと私に言っ
た どのようにあなたはあなたの髪を切ったのですか、
そしてそれは
あなたにとても似合う新しいコートです
ロジャーは彼の健康に興味を持っていることに加え
て自己維持に向けていくつかのステップ
を踏みました
プルームのメンバーは私がthaと言うときです
しばらく日本に住んでからしばらくすると誰もが素敵な服を着始めました
が、ロジャーはそれをまったく新しい
レベルに引き上げましたファズ-フェイクホークグリズリー
-ゴーティーパッチ-ほぼ一晩で
私が会ったオタク
はロックスターになりました
カオドラマサークルのアクティブメンバー
私は東京で同じような変化を遂げ、
自分が大人になり
、ライフスタイルの微妙な変化に気づきました
が、ロジャーがその
変化を経験し、YouTubeや現実で毎日それを見るの
はほぼ間違いありませんでした シュールな
[音楽]
みなさん、東京白鳥へようこそ
今週は原宿に行くことにしました
[音楽]
ロジャーがYouTubeで何千人
ものチャンネル登録者を
抱えていて、
私たちの寮の全員
が東京白鳥の各エピソードを心配そうに待っていた時間
は、プレイボーイが店内に持っていたものを見て、ロジャーは
彼のビデオで人々に触れ
、Yで数え切れないほど取り上げられました ouTube彼の正直な
勇気あるスタイルは、
彼が傲慢さのない一種の情熱を生み出したのを見ていたすべての人の心を捉え
ました。 学期
中に忙しくて
横須賀デリタのことを忘れてしまったような気がしますが、今ここ
にいるのはすごいみたいです
。13歳から14歳の頃にシミーをしていたみたいです。
ゲームこれはすごいです、そして私はそこに行きたいです
そして今ここで私は夢が叶うように聞こえるのでコーニーの
ようですあなたが知っている
最終的に私は寮
から私の新しいホストファミリーの家に引っ越しまし
た 私の反対側に住んでいたので、
スーツケースに
トレーニング機器
と高価な服を詰めた後、
川崎からコモトム、そしてロジャー
にカメラを持って行き
、私のお気に入りの思い出のもう1つを優雅に撮影しました。 彼と一緒に
いるので、このビデオの最後の部分は、
ここで本当に幸せなメモで終わります。隣に
住んでいる私の友人のケビンは、
あそこの壁を越えて
ホームステイプログラムに申し込んだでしょう。
彼はそれを手に入れました。
彼の日本人は今学期の初め
からすでに飛躍的に進歩しているので素晴らしいです。
私の
友人の東京ルークと私は先日彼の移動を手伝いました。彼
が鎌田に住んでいるのは素晴らしかったです。 さて、
それはまた別の活気のある場所です。
私が初めて行った
ときは本当に素晴らしいので、
カンマにいます。場所は素晴らしいようです。
やることはたくさんあると思い
ます。唯一の質問は東京です。
白鳥の嫉妬私は
それらのスーツケースをシーンまでずっとラグして、
それをマシン川崎駅と呼んでいることを決して忘れません。
それは絶対
にばかげてい
ました。
その時点からロジャーと私
は自分の道を歩み始めましたロジャーは
ケオの交換留学生の間でほとんど有名人でした、そして私はまだ
私の自由な時間のほとんどを当時の
ガールフレンドと過ごし
ていました幸いにも私たちは
クラスでほぼ毎日お互いに会いました 私たちの毎日の
会議はゆっくりとますます
まばらになりました私たちが会ったとき
私はいつも彼女に会うのを心配していました
私はいつも心配しすぎ
てい
ました
留学中の特別な人のために彼が持っていた甘いもの
がやがて終わり、
ついに別れを告げました。2008年7月下旬
にお互いに言ったことです。私は
ロジャー
だけでした。 プルームから積極的に連絡を取り合っているの
は、
米国に戻った後ですが、メールでも優雅なクリストマでも、フルームの誰も
がロジャーと連絡を取り合っていること
は知っています
カードロジャーは私たち全員に彼の日常生活を広げ、
私たちが愛するようになったイベントについて私たちに最新の情報を提供してくれました。私
は大学の最後の年に定期的に彼とメールを交換し
ました。  2008年12月にそのウェブサイトを更新したとき、私
は犬とトリックと呼ばれるウェブサイトを運営していましたが、
2008年12月にそのウェブサイトを更新したとき
、同じような興味や情熱を持った作家を探していました。
招待状を送り始めたときに最初に連絡したのは、
ロジャーが
すぐ
に犬とトリックの動画を書き始め、
落ち着いて、まったく新しい視聴者を急速に惹きつけたことを心から受け入れたとき、驚くことではありません
でした。 日本の文学作品で
あり、他の多くの作家や私とは異なり
、
彼は常にそれについて時間厳守でし
た。 スーパーブロガーの新しいステータス彼
は一貫して私のウェブサイトにしっかりと貢献しました
これは私が
知っていたロジャースワンですが、昨日亡くなったロジャースワンで
はありませんロジャーと私
は2009年4月にジェットプログラムに受け入れられました
ここで再び私の人生を見ました
ロジャーが彼の新しい仕事について書いたり、新しいシリーズのビデオについて話したりするときに、ロジャーと再調整しました。
彼は
みんなを東京の白鳥にすることを切望してい
ました。
私が受け入れられたことを多くの人が知っているので、私は本当に重要な発表で戻ってきまし
た。 ジェットプログラムだからええ私は本当に
興奮しています
私たちが日本にいることを知って良かったです
私たちは間違いなく戻ってきます
期待はよくありませんでした
正直に何を期待できるかわかりませんが私は
それに満足していますそして私は8月に最初に出発するのが待ちきれません
そして私は
8月2日に東京に戻っ
て数日間ジェットでオリエンテーションをします sそして
それから私は新しい県に引っ越します
そうそう私は今ここ
にいます本当に興奮していますそれは
素晴らしい素晴らしい新しい経験になるでしょう東京オリエンテーションで最後に
ロジャーに会えたらいいのにと思います
または
、クリスマス前にラテになりました。
残念ながら、ロジャーは
私とは異なるオリエンテーショングループに属していた
ので、北日本のジェットプログラムに割り当てられたロジャーとルークルークを訪ねるためにバイクに乗るのに休むことができませんでした。 トゥルーマンショーを見たことがあれば、今まで出会った中で最高の男性
の1人についての最後の段落を始めよう
とし
ています。そうすれば、
ロジャースの
存在と、ロジャースを知っているすべての人にとってのその重要性を理解できるかもしれません。
いつもビデオに出
ていた普通の男は誰もが成長するのを見ていた普通の男だっ
た私たちは彼が男の子から男に変わるのを見ました私たちは彼が成長するのを見ました
私たち全員の好奇心
ロジャーズのエゴの完全な欠如に夢中になり、催眠術をかけられました。
ロジャーズが成長するのを見ると、私たち
は彼にますます恋をしました。私たちは
彼の正常性に恋をしました。
私たちは彼の無私無欲に恋を
しました。 それでもロジャーのような人々
は世界に去りました彼は私が今まで出会った中で最も
普通の最も並外れた人
でした彼は隠すものがなく、
希望を持っていた人を軽視する人もいませんでした
ただ彼
はロジャー・スワンであり、
彼を知っているすべての人の輝かしい光でした。これは
昨日亡くなったロジャー・スワンです。私たちの誰もが
彼が笑顔
になる
ことを決して忘れません。
10年前に亡くなった友人のロジャースワン
が日本の県を歩いて10周年を迎えるのを祝う
ために、私はここYouTube
で私たちの男道元のためにビデオを作っています。  dこのビデオを始める
には
、ロジャーのために作られた巨大なムージルイジウィンター
サンセットという曲を聴きます。これはシェンミュー3で取り上げられた曲でした。
ロジャー
はビデオゲームシリーズシェンミューを愛し、
幸運にも彼は彼に捧げられた曲
を サウンドトラックだからこれを聴こう
[音楽]
[拍手]
[拍手]  ]
[音楽]
[拍手]
[ 音楽]
[音楽]
[拍手]
【拍手】
【音楽
】綺麗な曲としては綺麗な
曲です著作権の問題でその曲が切り取られ
てすみませんが、ここで聴く機会がない場合はチェックしてみてください
シェンムー3のサウンドトラックからの冬の日没のユウジユウチですシェンムー3の
サウンドトラックだと思います
が、ええ
、過去のビデオで言われていなかったロジャーについて何が言えるかわからないので、チェックして
ください。
ロジャーについて話すのは好きではありませ
んそれはいつも
私自身の死を思い出させてくれます私
自身の年齢の誰か
がとてもランダムに死ぬ
可能性が
あります あなたが
将来の大使のように将来の大使である
と
あなたが見ることができる人たちは、世界のどこかでアメリカの大使を知っ
ているか、彼がビル・ゲイツのような誰かである
か、スティーブ・ジョブズのようなスティーブ・ジョブズであるの
を見ることができ
ます 彼
が亡くなったとき
、この世界で最大の種類だと
感じただけで、私が最初に日本に来たことを知ることができたのは公平
ではありませんでした。
私がコールする多くの人々 私の年齢の友達で、
特にYouTubeでは、私とロジャーを除い
て、YouTubeの動画を定期的にやっている年齢の人は誰もいない
ようでした。そのため、彼との小さな絆のおかげで
、私
たちは それだけで、それで私たちは
より良い友達になりました。
ロジャースの
誕生日のようなものや、ロジャーが家にいたときのような
ものを知っています。私は彼の最高の一人ではないことを知ってい
ます。 友達は家に帰っ
て
いましたが、彼が生きていたときに私たちがここにいたとき
のつながりを知っていると感じました。ロジャーは
私よりもはるかに優れた男でした。
私の代わりに彼がやったらいいのにと思いましたが、
彼はとても謙虚で、とても地味で、
素晴らしいクールな趣味を持っていたので
、ホラー映画が好き
でした。 彼はもっとfになった
当時よりも日本語で流暢である私は
いつもラッキーな宝くじを手に入れた
ような気がします
ロジャーのことを考えたり、彼が
死にかけていることを考えると、いつも気分が悪くなります。なぜなら、
IIが運
が良かったのは、彼が私のために弾丸を受け取ったのだと知っているからです。
彼のおかげで私
はより良い人になりたいと
思ってい
ます。彼
がサーフィンをしているのは
短時間でしたが、
彼がここにいたとき、彼は多くの人々に影響を与えました、
そしてあなたは彼がポップスターではないことを知って
います彼は政治家ではありません彼は
ユーチューブチャンネルでミシガンからのクールな男
でした 彼の
古いビデオを見てください まだYouTubeで
それらを見ることができ、
コメントを残す
ことができます。気に入ったものや
、記憶を維持するために知っているものは何でも、彼には
いくつかのFacebookグループもあります。参加できると思いますが
、私たち全員かどうかはわかりません。
死ぬつもりですが、最終的
に私が
バケツを蹴ったら、人々が私が今ロジャーを祝っている方法で私を祝ってくれること
を願って
います 私はまだ彼を使う必要があり
ます